أخيرًا وجدت دراسة جديدة أن
الثعابين تحصل على القليل من المساعدة من
أصدقائها مثلما نفعل تمامًا. قام
الباحثون بدراسة الأفاعي الجرسية في
المواقف العصيبة، حيث وضعوا
الثعابين في دلاء كبيرة وأغلقوها
وضربوا الدلاء بالأنابيب باستخدام
أجهزة مراقبة القلب، وتتبع الباحثون
مستويات التوتر لدى الحيوانات
ووجدوا أن أولئك الذين لديهم رفاق لديهم
معدلات ضربات قلب أقل من أولئك الذين كانوا
بمفردهم ويأمل العلماء أن
يساعد البحث الأشخاص الذين يرغبون في الاحتفاظ بالثعابين كحيوانات أليفة
وربما إلقاء نظرة أكثر إيجابية على الثعابين.
أعتقد أنه بالنسبة لنا كبشر  يتيح لنا أن
نعرف أننا لسنا مختلفين كثيرًا
عن هذه الثعابين، فأنت تعلم أنهم يفعلون
شيئًا نفعله أيضًا
ويخبرنا أيضًا أن هناك أشياء أكثر تعقيدًا
تحدث معهم وأنهم
أكثر اجتماعية مما كنا عليه في الأصل
صدقهم أن يكونوا